[Aplausos]
muchas gracias
durante muchos años habíamos pensado que
ser inteligentes era la capacidad de
estas personas que sabían muchas cosas o
que almacenaban muchos datos en su
memoria y eso es una parte de la
inteligencia lo que llamamos la
inteligencia cristalizada pero hay
muchas más inteligencias sabemos que la
inteligencia es la capacidad para
resolver problemas problemas de todo
tipo problemas en el trabajo problemas
en los estudios problemas de la vida
cotidiana pero también problemas en
nuestras interacciones sociales de hecho
hoy en día cada vez cobra más
importancia la inteligencia emocional y
determinados estudios nos dicen que las
el 85% de las competencias de los
líderes de las organizaciones son
competencias socio emocionales qué es
esto de la inteligencia emocional la
inteligencia emocional es la capacidad
para en un primer momento entender
cuáles son las emociones que estamos
sintiendo ser conscientes de lo que
estamos sintiendo tanto nosotros mismos
como las personas que nos rodean
comprender por qué nos sentimos así
poner nombre y ser capaz de verbalizar
lo que nosotros sentimos y lo que
sienten los demás utilizar además las
emociones a nuestro favor y no nuestras
contra las emociones nos pueden ayudar a
hacer una toma de decisiones
precisamente mucho más inteligente y por
último la última habilidad de la
inteligencia emocional es la capacidad
para regular las emociones seguro que a
todos se ha pasado que en ocasiones nos
hemos de quedado presos de una
determinada emoción y en lugar de
responder hemos reaccionado de forma
automática y a veces hemos dicho cosas
pues que a lo mejor nos hemos
arrepentido un poco todo esto es lo que
hace la inteligencia emocional y hay
mucha gente que piensa que la
inteligencia emocional es algo que está
como muy de moda que es una cosa como
muy reciente cuando fijaros porque ya
sabes
wing hablaba de la importancia de las
capacidades afectivas e incluso nos
decía que no es la especie más fuerte la
que sobrevive ni la más inteligente sino
la que mejor responde y se adapta al
cambio hoy en día en la sociedad en la
que vivimos que todo cambia tan deprisa
y un año para otro cambian las formas de
relacionarnos cambian las formas de
comunicarnos cambian las familias
cambian los trabajos cambian los amigos
creéis que es importante adaptarnos a
los cambios yo creo que es fundamental y
para eso va a ser muy importante ser
flexibles y además tener una muy buena
tolerancia a la frustración creéis que
estamos preparados para ello
y es más a los niños les estamos
enseñando estas capacidades que sabemos
que van a ser fundamentales para
conseguir éxito en la sociedad hoy en
día
yo trabajo como psicóloga y a mí me
gusta pues sobre todo cuando trabajo con
familias cuando trabajo con niños y con
niñas el primer día que vengan los
padres les hacemos muchas preguntas les
hacemos una buena historia clínica
porque tenemos que tener pues un buen
análisis funcional para saber qué es lo
que les ocurre pero a la hora de
terminar siempre me gusta terminar con
una pregunta que es bueno en definitiva
qué es lo que quieres conseguir para tu
hijo para tu hija aquí quieres que yo te
ayude sabes cuál es la respuesta que
siempre o casi siempre nos dan yo lo que
quiero es que sea feliz que mi hijo que
mi hija sea feliz y es algo que es
absolutamente razonable aspirar a esa
felicidad tanto para nosotros mismos
como para las personas pues que quizás
son las más importantes de nuestra vida
nuestros hijos pero si queremos que sean
felices
habrá que prepararles para la vida
porque porque si no cuentan con
herramientas no cuentan con técnicas no
saben muy bien cómo actuar
es muy complicado ser feliz entonces qué
es lo que tenemos que hacer vamos a
prepararles para la vida y en ocasiones
como lo que queremos es nada venga que
sean muy felices qué es lo que pasa que
prácticamente hacemos todo lo contrario
y caemos en lo que los psicólogos
llamamos insistimos tanto de la
sobreprotección y les metemos en una
burbuja en el que que no les pase nada
que no que no sufran que no bueno ya es
pequeñito ya se tendrá que esforzar
cuando sea mayor ya lo pasará mal ya
tendrá tiempo entonces para qué le voy a
despertar un poquito antes y que se
vista solo que duerma y luego no se sabe
vestir o para qué va a preparar en la
mochila bueno ya se la preparó yo ya se
la llevo yo y luego no se sabe
planificar y luego no se sabe organizar
cuando llega el futuro o no le voy a
decir que no porque si no se va a
frustrar y cuántos nos vamos a recibir a
lo largo de nuestra vida eso no
significa que haya que decir que no a
todo que a veces también ahí se nos va
un poco un poco rápido o les compramos
muchas cosas sobre todo las cosas que
más nos hubiera gustado tener a nosotros
de pequeño que hoy en día por las
jugueterías
más de cosas preciosas la verdad pero
creéis que hay algún estudio que
relaciona que ser feliz tiene que ver
con tener muchos juguetes
o tener muchos bolsos en el armario para
una mujer o tener un coche más potente
porque esto no ocurre así ningún estudio
relaciona la felicidad con tener muchas
cosas de tipo material o lo que hacemos
es que les apuntamos a todo sabemos que
es muy bueno que hagan deporte que lo es
que hablen idiomas que también lo es que
practiquen instrumentos que también lo
es cuál es el problema cuando perdemos
hay un poco el sentido común y queremos
que lo hagan todo a la vez y al final
qué es lo que está pasando que tenemos
niños hiperestimulados que tienen muchas
cosas que tienen muchas actividades pero
les falta algo que es fundamental que es
tiempo y a veces tiempo libre para que
para ser ellos los que dirijan su vida
para que en ellos los que en un
determinado momento elijan a qué jugar
qué hacer que aprendan también a dirigir
su conducta y esto es algo que es
fundamental
otra cosa que nos ocurre bueno bengasi
ante cualquier problema a mí no me
cuesta nada ayudarte si yo no voy a
tardar nada así es que yo te quiero
mucho ya te lo hago yo qué pasa qué
mensaje va implícito si aquí está súper
mamá o súper papá para ayudarte para
hacértelo todo el mensaje implícito es
yo puedo pero tú no puedes y esto que va
en contra de su seguridad en contra de
esa autoestima y es más no estamos
trabajando con los niños esa partida de
ese valor de ser autónomos y aprender
primero a resolver las cosas ante un
problema qué es lo que tenemos que
educar tú inténtalo arreglar y si no
puedes por supuesto que puedes pedir
ayuda y aquí estoy yo para ayudarte pero
primero lo intentamos en primera persona
porque sabemos que el agente mejor
posicionado para trabajar la
inteligencia emocional son las familias
las familias pueden hacer muchísimo es
verdad que si además pues estamos en un
colegio donde se hacen programas de
inteligencia emocional pues todavía va a
ser mucho mejor pero las familias somos
esa gente mejor posicionado pero también
podemos ser la fuente también de el
mayor enemigo de la inteligencia
emocional y el mayor enemigo de la
inteligencia emocional es la
sobreprotección
cuando estamos hablando de padres de
madres que están sobre protegiendo a sus
hijos creéis que es porque no les
quieren en absoluto lo que está pasando
es que se está mal entendiendo el amor
maternal o paternal como te quiero tanto
hay para que te vas a esforzar que te lo
hago yo y no nos estamos dando cuenta
que les estamos haciendo un flaco favor
porque los niños tienen que tener un
vínculo de seguridad tenemos que
fomentar un apego seguro con los niños
no apegos que fomenten la dependencia
porque estaríamos generando un apego de
tipo inseguro y eso va a interferir en
el correcto desarrollo de las
capacidades emocionales de nuestros
hijos al final se trata de no tanto
preparar el camino para tus hijos sino a
tus hijos para el camino que sean
capaces de andar en todas las
superficies cuando el camino ya no está
bien asfaltado y está todo marcado
fenomenal perfecto que vayan disfrutando
pero si en algún momento está embarrado
se vuelve más escarpado hay charcos no
se saben bien por dónde ir que ellos
también sean capaces en definitiva qué
es lo que se trata
no evitar que los niños se caigan no
evitar que no les pase nada sino
enseñarles a levantarse porque porque
además sabemos que el error es una de
las mejores fuentes de aprendizaje de
hecho hay un aprendizaje que se llama
así aprendizaje por ensayo por error y
esto se ve muy bien en los niños cuando
son chiquititos que van jugando a las
cosas que van viendo os acordáis cuando
vuestros hijos sean pequeños y tenían
que meter los taurus en cositas así en
plan de plástico ir viendo cómo se metía
cada uno como lo hacían probando uno y
otro si no les permitimos que se
equivoquen creéis que se puede dar este
tipo de aprendizaje
está claro que no vamos a utilizar el
error como fuente de aprendizaje pero
para eso necesitamos tres cosas
fundamentales la primera de todas es que
si un niño se equivoca qué hacemos
porque a veces lo que nos sale es dios
mío te has equivocado hay que repetir
los deberes o uff hay que volver a hacer
la redacción y parece que es algo
dramático cuando no hay que dramatizar
el error te has equivocado vale lo
reconocemos lo corregimos y ya está y en
segundo lugar los primeros que tenemos
que reconocer los errores quiénes somos
nosotros mismos porque todos y cada uno
de nosotros todos los que estamos aquí
hemos cometido algún error incluso 23 y
muchos más porque no somos perfectos
porque todos nos equivocamos y es
importante que nuestros hijos vean que
reconocemos cuando hemos cometido un
error y en tercer lugar hay que aprender
de él tampoco valeri garcía bueno pues
no pasa nada no
asumo que he cometido ese error lo
reconozco y buscó la forma de
solucionarlo porque además de esta forma
vamos a enseñar a los niños el cómo
hacerlo vivimos además en una sociedad
de tiempos líquidos hemos dicho que todo
cambia muy muy deprisa y que tenemos que
tener una muy buena capacidad de
adaptación si queremos realmente tener
éxito en la exigente sociedad de hoy el
mismo de hoy en día va a ser fundamental
el que pues que hagamos algo que fijaros
porque ya estaba escrito en el templo
apolo en grecia que es conócete a ti
mismo y comprende a los demás pero para
esto que necesitamos una variable
fundamental que es el tiempo tiempo para
hacer esa introspección tiempo para
conocernos tiempo para pararnos también
y conocer a los demás y hoy en día es
quizás lo que más nos falta porque pues
porque en ocasiones vamos todos con unos
aparatos en el bolsillo que nos permiten
el que la conexión
a un mundo en el que no nos deja muchas
veces hacer esa capacidad de
introspección de hecho vamos no incluso
con el cargador ahí externo por si ante
el drama que nos quedemos sin batería y
no nos podamos conectar y saber de los
demás
por eso retomando hay un poco qué es lo
que pasa cuando el niño nos dice que se
aburre estaba muy relacionado también
con el tiempo que es lo que hacemos
automáticamente a que no se aburra le
entre tenemos le damos un dispositivo
electrónico cuando es importante
aprender a aburrirnos es importante a
estar con nosotros mismos porque la
única persona que tenemos garantizada
que nos va a acompañar el resto de
nuestra vida quienes somos nosotros
mismos y no sabemos estar a gusto con
nosotros mismos vamos a tener un
problema y además os aseguro que no hay
documentada ninguna muerte por
aburrimiento
pero tomamos el tema de la felicidad
hemos dicho queremos que los niños sean
felices pero es que ser feliz no
significa estar todo el día alegre y
todo el día dando botes así haciendo
cosas ser feliz qué significa que soy
capaz de entender en todo momento las
emociones que estoy sintiendo tanto las
emociones que son agradables como la
alegría como la calma pero también las
emociones desagradables cuando somos
capaces de reconocerlas de comprenderlas
de entenderlas y de gestionarlas vamos a
ser mucho más felices y por eso vamos a
enseñar a los niños a hacerlo y para eso
cómo lo vamos a hacer lo primero de todo
generando un clima de confianza es muy
difícil que un niño o una niña nos dice
que cómo se siente si ese clima de
confianza no lo hemos generado pero
también nos pasa a los adultos yo no voy
a contar cómo me siento en un clima que
veo que sea hostil y en ocasiones hemos
escuchado una charla nos han dicho hoy
vamos a hablar de emociones con los
hijos y parece que bengalas despachamos
entre una actividad y otra cuando nos da
tiempo no así no funciona hay que
generar el clima reservando un tiempo
espacio y además hay que compartir las
emociones los primeros que tenemos que
decir cómo nos sentimos somos nosotros
los adultos hay gente que piensa que es
que esto de decir las emociones es como
de débiles cuando en absoluto es así
porque las emociones nos hacen humanos y
los niños deberían de aprender el nombre
de las emociones básicas a la vez que el
nombre de los colores y por supuesto
muchísimo antes que determinados
contenidos escolares
y hay que trabajar como reconocer y como
expresar esas emociones primero
empezamos en uno mismo siendo consciente
qué es lo que siento vale vamos a
enseñarles además un vocabulario
emocional básico que sean capaces de
nombrar las emociones empezaremos por
las emociones básicas las más fáciles
para luego ir introduciendo el nombre de
emociones más complejas pero se las
vamos a ir enseñando y cuando sepan
hacer esto a partir de entorno más o
menos de los tres sobre todo cuatro
añitos ya podemos enseñarles a reconocer
las emociones en los demás y que además
también un poco sepan nombrarlas lo
vamos a ir haciendo de forma progresiva
y una cosa que es fundamental que nos
pasa mucho no hay que invalidar las
emociones que nos pasa cuando vemos a un
niño llorar al niño enfadado no llores
no te enfades o lo que todavía es peor
pero si no es para tanto que estamos
haciendo con eso estamos invalidando sus
emociones de hecho si hacemos todo lo
contrario decimos
estás triste verdad o estás enfadado
veremos que muchas veces ya solamente
con eso se van a aprender a calmar y
esto muchas veces genera muchas dudas
porque una cosa es la emoción que es lo
que yo estoy sintiendo y otra cosa es la
conducta qué es lo que yo hago yo puedo
estar enfadada
y puedo validar la emoción entiendo que
estás enfadado que tu hijo está enfadado
pero otra cosa diferente es pegar o
gritar o insultar
eso ya es una conducta y eso no lo
validamos entiendo que estás enfadado
pero eso no te da derecho a gritar oa
insultar o a pegar o lo que sea que haya
pasado en esa conducta y además hay que
trabajar la comprensión emocional es
decir comprender bien en qué estado
emocional estamos para eso es
fundamental lo que hemos dicho antes de
poderlo nombrar y poderlo nombrar bien
porque porque hay niños que
malinterpretan las las situaciones
cuando son ambiguas las emociones que
sienten los demás y luego tienen
conductas agresivas precisamente por eso
además hay que trabajar el autocontrol
cuando somos capaces de decidir cómo
actuamos qué es lo que vamos a sentir en
un determinado momento también nos va a
dar un gran poder pero lo que tenemos
que hacer es aprender a gestionar las
emociones no reprimir las pero tampoco
dejarnos atrapar por ellas y ser
y sobre todo recordar hemos dicho que la
sobreprotección es un gran enemigo para
el desarrollo de la inteligencia
emocional luego no vamos a sobreproteger
a los niños
en definitiva si queremos mejorar el
mundo tenemos que enseñar a los niños
tenemos que poner toda la carga sobre
ellos porque ellos son los que van a
cambiar el mundo y sobre todo porque lo
que queremos es hacer un mundo
emocionalmente mucho más inteligente
muchas gracias